this video is sponsored by mubi
[Music]
why is it green
do you think
the night
yes
why is the green knight green
at almost the exact halfway point in the
green knight there's an achingly slow
360 degree pan
just before the shot gowen who is on a
quest the purpose of which neither he
nor the viewers really seem to
understand is waylaid by thieves and
left tied up on the ground in the forest
to die
the pace of this pan creates suspense
you feel what's coming at the other end
of the pan must be important
but the real beauty of the pan is that
you slowly realize what you're going to
see at the end of it before you get
there as it progresses winter turns to
spring time is passing and you realize
that only two options are available for
the outcome of this shot gowin will
either have escaped or he's going to be
a corpse and as the pan progresses even
further you realize which of these
outcomes it will be before you even see
the result you hear it
i will do it
i will meet him gowan has engaged in a
bizarre game on christmas day a green
knight shows up in king arthur's court
with a challenge he will fight a willing
opponent and if this opponent can land a
blow against him in one year's time the
green knight will return that blow you
understand this challenge
i do
i think i do
this is a bizarre film based on a
bizarre story from the 14th century and
director david lowry's adaptation
which heavily modifies the original text
leans into the weirdness
there's a lot of different themes it
explores and a lot of symbolic imagery
godwin is struggling with becoming a
knight what it means to be a man his
mommy issues his responsibility to his
lover etc but the thing lowry is most
preoccupied with in the film is the
thing that the green knight himself
symbolizes
in the forest for a moment lowry gives
us a glimpse of one possible outcome of
the story one where gowen dies on the
forest floor
but no sooner does he give us this
glimpse then he spins the camera back
around effectively winding back the
clock he just wound forward and there we
find gowin still alive and he's able to
free himself
but why is so much time spent on this
moment what is up with this shot is this
a bizarre red herring some kind of fake
out pseudo twist
so much time is spent on this moment
surely it must play a significant role
in understanding the story
what is the true nature of the game
cohen is playing
at every step he seems unsure and the
people around him don't offer much
consolation or guidance but one thing
seems clear the green knight said he
would deliver back whatever blow was
given him
and we know what this means for godwin
gowen knows he's walking towards his own
death and if death awaits me and while a
lot of the people around him seem sure
that there will be something after his
meeting with the green knight i mean
your journey home
after
he himself is not so sure
and it's assumed by all that just not
playing the game skipping out on his
date with the green knight at the chapel
isn't even an option
do you believe in magic this is a film
that will make zero sense if you look at
it in a very literal way in which craft
do you believe in it
yeah
i do
it's all around us the world that godwin
inhabits is an enchanted one lowry
imbues the film with a sense of this
enchantment
look around you young
what you see
in moments like this one see how he cuts
to a pendant around someone's neck i see
legends for seemingly no reason
it's moves like this in the editing and
with the camera work that emphasize the
symbolic magical nature of the story to
understand the film we have to look at
the game gowan is playing symbolically
and to understand what the game gowan is
playing symbolizes we need to know
what the green knight at least in
lowry's universe symbolizes the grain is
the color of earth of living things of
life
and a fraud
yes in this moment the lady of the house
lays on the table the key to
understanding the green knight lowry
deftly links this monologue to the
earlier scene of gowin's death in the
forest by bringing the same audio cues
into the mix in both scenes we hear
birdsong indicating spring flies
indicating decay wind and thunder when
you go your footprints will fill with
grass
moss shall cover your tombstone and as
the sun rises green shall spread over
all
and all its shades and ears
[Music]
this third degree will overtake your
swords and your coins and your
battlements and try as you might all
your whole deer will succumb to it
your skin
your bones
the green of the green knight is the
green of decay of time it's the new life
that springs out of death and covers
over it it's the green that no armor or
nightly station can defend against
i live in the midst of the appalachian
mountains which are said to be some of
the oldest mountains on earth geologists
say that these mountains were once
taller than the himalayas but have been
worn down by time in contrast to younger
mountain ranges that are still forming
like the himalayas the appalachian
mountains are much smaller
and much greener
in facing the green knight gawan is
facing his own death but not his literal
death at the hands of the knight himself
his inevitable inescapable death at the
hands of time a death that will happen
no matter what he does in this life
[Music]
the seventh seal another medieval period
piece about a knight playing a game for
his life there's an interesting moment
towards the middle of the film a monk
interrupts a play being performed by a
traveling stage troop to deliver these
remarks
[Music]
it's hard not to see the monk as
interrupting not just the play in the
film but the film itself to deliver a
message that bergman wants us to hear a
very real message about our own
mortality and the necessity of
confronting it
this moment in the woods this long pan
isn't just about portraying gowan's own
vision of his death if he doesn't act to
save himself it's a period of time that
lowry gives us to contemplate death
itself the passing of time and our own
mortality lowry isn't just putting death
on screen as a plot point he's
confronting us with it and he wants us
to think about it he's done this before
in his work his film a ghost story is
essentially a guided meditation on grief
death and time it has very little
dialogue but around the halfway point
this guy interrupts the film to deliver
a tirade about death and decay and the
ultimate meaninglessness of everything
in the face of the destruction of the
universe at the hands of time your kids
are gonna die yours too yours too
hey just saying they're all gonna die
it's a move that is a huge turn off
nobody likes this guy lowry's direction
seems to even acknowledge that this
character is literally the you must be
fun at parties trope his shirt is sweat
stained and the people around him don't
seem that interested in what he has to
say while i like a ghost story it's not
at all subtle in its exploration of
these themes i think lowry found a more
interesting way to force the audience to
ponder death in the green knight but
people still hate this stuff at least
two people walked out of the screening
of the green knight i was in both movies
have a lot of detractors many don't like
them simply because they're weird and
slow or it's not their thing but i think
a decent number of people just don't
like a downer they don't want to think
about death much less in a theater where
they came to escape but whether you see
meaninglessness in the face of death or
believe in something that transcends
death or offers meaning in spite of it
it's a reality everyone has to face
this is
really all there is
what else are they'd be
going like most of us is not that
interested in confronting his own death
and luckily he is given an enchanted
cord to tie around his waist as long as
he wears it there no harm can come to
him
he uses it at the end of the film to
escape the green knight in the chapel
and live out his life becoming king
marrying and having children and once
again lowry presents us with a slow
360 degree pan followed by another image
of gowon's death as he decides to remove
the cord as he removes the cord he is
beheaded showing us he never really
escaped the green knight's blow
his death of old age is the same death
he faced in the chapel both deaths are
the same both are deaths at the hand of
time
lowry once again rewinds the time he
wound forward and we find gohwan still
in the green chapel alive
gowan realizes there is no escaping the
green knight even if he flees the chapel
time and decay will eventually catch up
with him the game is not about escaping
the green knight but about your attitude
in the face of your own death
is it possible to win that game
lowry leaves it somewhat ambiguous but i
think for galwan his acceptance of death
in the chapel offers him a kind of
freedom
after he removes the cord making himself
vulnerable to the green knight the green
knight allows him to go free without
taking the blow in the chapel
we know he can't truly escape death and
decay but now he faces life with courage
i'm ready now
the green knight is green because he
represents the new life that comes forth
out of death and finding the courage to
face his death gowan finds courage to
live his life
the green knight is very weird and if
that's your thing and you want to go
even further into the weirdness and the
symbolism you could check out
jodorowsky's the holy mountain which is
available right now in the us on mubi my
sponsor for this video movie is an
online streaming cinema that is hand
curated every day they add a new film
with an explanation of why it's worth
your time i love mubi i've been watching
stuff on there for a long time they're a
great way to find new independent art
house classic and international cinema
movies amazing hand curated library is
available all around the world and you
can try it for free for 30 days right
now when you click the link in the
description to sign up for your extended
free trial go to movie.com
thomasflight.mubi.com
thomasflight or click the link on the
screen to get 30 days of mubi for free
[Music]
if you want more insight into what i
watch every month in my patreon podcast
i give quick spoiler free reviews of
every movie that i watch get access to
this and support my channel when you
sign up to become a patron at
patreon.com thomasflight